recently Union's been balancing all our
members for National strike action in
the fight for fair pay and well the
ballot results are end here to make the
announcement the short statement is FB
General Secretary Matt rack Matt thanks
Tom uh hi everyone uh to be clear the
fire brigade Union has had to conduct
three separate ballots and we'll give
three separate announcements uh because
of legal requirements uh members will be
aware that we're required to meet
certain thresholds
both in general and also as a important
Public Service I can confirm that in
each of the three cases we have
decisively uh meet uh match the ballot
thresholds and I think the results I'm
about to announce can uh confirm the
level of anger and determination that
our members have over the falling pay
that we've experienced over the past 12
years so the results are in relation to
the aggregated ballots for England
Scotland and Wales fbu members have
voted by 88 for a strike
in Northern Ireland fbu members have
voted by 94 for a strike in Northwest
Fire Control fbu members have voted by
80 for a strike so I can confirm that in
each of the three ballots our members
have voted for strike action and in each
of the three cases our members have
decisively beaten the thresholds set by
the Trade union legislation as required
on this Union
and Mark that is clearly a remarkable
result and as you see it does show the
anger felt by firefighters and
firefighters control over low paying the
service well we thought we've been
receiving questions from Members
obviously over the ballot period and we
thought we'd take this opportunity for
you to answer some of them some of them
are commonly asked is it where so number
one is well what happens now you've got
the result said a decisive Nova realm
and yes what when will strike action
happen and who decides the type of
strike action
so uh first of all the executive Council
decided over a week ago at a previous
meeting that we would not call strike
action immediately uh members will
recall we have written to the fire
service employers we've also written
back to the UK government we've sought a
meeting of the national Joint Council
and we agreed to delay the calling of
strike action by 10 days in order to
allow the employers to consider the
outcome of today's votes and to meet us
and to revise their offer I'm pleased
that the employers have agreed to meet
us and that meeting will now take place
on the 8th of February that's an
important date for us and we will delay
calling of any strike action until at
least the 9th of February but my message
to the fire service employers is this
don't waste that opportunity
firefighters don't want to see a strike
firefighters want to see a resolution to
this dispute but the only way that can
be achieved is by receiving through the
national Joint Council a new and
significantly improved payoffer that our
executive council is willing to put to
our members for their consideration so
you have a limited time you need to
think seriously you need to take account
of the level of anger that is reflected
in those absolutely remarkable uh yes
votes of firefighters voting for strike
action
in terms of uh if strike action is
called that will be a matter for the
executive Council Tam uh Brigade
committees have been meeting Regional
committees have been meeting those views
are fed through to the executive Council
and strike action if it is called on the
9th of February will be determined and
decided by the executive Council but
just be clear members can input into
that process what by meeting locally and
feeding their views up yeah and I've
attended a number of meetings of that
nature term where members have different
views and there are inevitably in the
union differing views and we have to
listen to the views of of everyone
and that can be then taken to a brigade
committee for voting and then taken to a
regional committee for voting and then
brought here to the executive Council
who will ultimately make the call for
strike action okay now Mark you
mentioned what the campaign names are
this is about for European both you and
I've been across the country hearing
some some quite devastating stories
about the impact of be in firefighters
and firefighters control our members of
a whelmingly reject the five percent pay
offer which begs the next question who
will decide what Fair pay actually is is
it executive council is it members
what's the process that's a a really
vital question uh Tom and it's one
that's come up in the media and uh to be
clear in this ballot I certainly haven't
had a vote uh I didn't have a vote on
accepting or rejecting the five percent
that's a matter for our members to
decide we're a democratic organization
and I think the fact that we balloted
our members on the five percent is has
given us a very clear Democratic mandate
from our members to go to the next stage
which is the strike ballots and our
members have spoken even more clearly
this time with much higher uh figures
for the yes folks I hope that the
employers will take account of that in
the next 10 days
and in terms of what will settle the
dispute again that is a matter for the
membership to decide but what I would
say to the fire service employers is
this don't play games with us it's too
late for playing games we've been trying
to resolve this pay claim since May of
last year we're now uh almost in
February of the following year and our
members have now got to the stage of
voting overwhelmingly for strike action
so the fire service employers need to
sit up take notice listen to the level
of anger and frustration of our members
our members are prepared to take that
action if necessary but you now have the
chance to make a revised offer and our
members would decide whether that offer
is acceptable or not okay much to the
ball is very firmly in the employer's
court at the moment but what can members
do to help build this campaign help
build this strike action is there
anything the members out there know
should be looking to do look I think our
members have played an absolutely
fantastic role throughout this you know
we've been all over the UK talking to
members hearing their experiences
hearing the hardships that our members
are increasingly suffering with the cost
of living crisis and stagnating pay
Members need to stand together and stay
determined I think that's what's been
reflected every step of the way like
we're clear that some Chief Fire
officers some politicians have been
saying oh oh don't worry about it
they'll accept five percent don't worry
about it they will never vote for strike
action we've proved them wrong every
step of the way and if they keep
standing in a way we will prove them
wrong again so the biggest thing our
members can do is to stay organized
attend the branch meetings participate
in the discussions participate in the
union take up the roles as Union
officials Union reps and the station the
Fire Control or whatever if we call
events and as they've been meetings and
lobbies and activities across the
country and nationally participating
knows send a firm message to our
employers to Chief officers and to the
government that were not prepared to
accept ever falling standards of living
and they need to do something about it
that's what members can do absolutely no
just finally with you and I've been
associated in the fire rescue service
for many years naughty in that
profession take strike action lightly so
we know there's several thousand people
watching this now both members and
supporters what would be your message to
them now you've got them here what would
be your message to them at this month
look I would like to first of all thank
all our members for The Marvelous
solidarity they have shown over the
course of quite a long campaign now but
also the wider supporters you're right
that there is a growing mood of anger in
the country that workers whether it's in
the fire service other public services
or elsewhere are paying the price for
failure in the economy failure of
politicians failures that we didn't
cause that we didn't make decisions
about uh but we're asked to tighten our
belts endlessly so that demonstration of
unity and solidarity across across the
labor movement but particularly within
the fire brigade Union I want to thank
our members for for that for their
determination for their unity and for
their solidarity and for participating
in this campaign including these
fantastic results that we are announcing
today we need to carry on standing
together the only way we will make
progress on this the only way we will
deliver improve moved outcomes for our
members that can actually change
people's lives by improving living
standards the only way we'll do that is
by standing together standing United and
that's what I urge everyone to do in the
coming weeks Mark that's a strong
message if any satellite streams up
thanks very much for joining us and
thanks very much madrak thanks Tom and
thanks everyone for watching and thanks
everyone for your participation and your
unity and solidarity